let's go next to Jack from Connecticut
Jack from Connecticut welcome to the
program
good morning David can you hear me I can
hear you fine
wonderful it's nice to be back I like to
bring up a personal topic today okay
personal to you or to me
uh personal to me but it kind of kind of
relates to everyone in this audience
sort of sure
um so about a couple of weeks ago uh
President Biden announced that the
federal government will be ending the
covet emergency yep on the federal scale
and that hits personal to me for two
reasons yes uh number one it's out the
date is May 11th which is also my
birthday okay and number and number two
it's also the day before the three year
anniversary of my grandmother passing
from this deadly and very real disease
okay um
so I just wanted to ask you a question
about this sure um do you think this is
a real light at the end of the tunnel in
terms of the end of the code emergency
or do you see this as Biden's way of
easing into the gop's demands given the
high stakes negotiations regarding
budget and the deficit ceiling listen so
there's there's sort of two parts to
this the first part is does Biden ending
the covet emergency
change anything about the reality of
what's happening with covid out in the
world the answer is of course not it's a
political determination it's a political
change we haven't we have an emergency
we don't have if right now I do I was
president and I declared Ebola an
emergency it wouldn't change anything
about ebola it would just be a political
designation
so the first thing is this isn't really
meaningful in terms of covid now in
terms of do I think that the the covet
is over no covet's not over when you
look at Global cases and deaths they are
down quite a bit and they continue to
decline
and there's the question of whether we
say is this now
part of the background level of risk
sort of like you could go out and get
the flu and you're aware of it you could
go out and get coveted and you're aware
of it but we now say we are not
considering covid something special
we're saying Cove it's still there but
we're sort of including it in the total
risk of going out and you might get a
stomach bug or the flu or get hit by a
car whatever the case may be I I don't
know when the right time is
I don't think that what Biden is doing
is really being pushed or that he's
being kind of pressured
by Republicans necessarily I mean very
few people are talking about the Federal
Emergency designation anyway
uh and most people aren't acting like
anything is going on anyway so I I think
that it's really more of a political
decision and maybe even a financial
decision but I think really to figure
out what's going on you need to be
looking at data that is totally separate
from anything Joe Biden says
yeah it's very unfortunate that this
whole Fiasco has turned into a political
situation especially coming from someone
who lost a beloved family member from
this terrible disease but uh fortunately
at the time not fortunately I'm sorry uh
at the time there wasn't adequate
testing available right so there was no
way to point out anything in a sense but
it's very fortunate to know that um
things have improved in some way and um
there's some way we can see some light
at the end of the tunnel if that makes
sense yeah yeah no question about it and
um a lot of the light at the end of the
tunnel depends on personal risk
tolerance and a lot of things that are
different for everybody so I appreciate
the call Jack and be well okay
thank you very much David I appreciate
it all right there is Jack from
Connecticut bringing up a number of
important issues let's go next to oh I
don't know how about Jose in New York
Jose welcome to the program
and David it's by the way it's um it's
Portuguese but I'm very impressed you
got the last name correct I didn't even
say the last name
uh no I'm sorry last time uh when I was
uh twitching but anyway okay so my
question is to you is um
when the like
back in like the 1800s and during the
turn of the labor unions yeah and such
like that when people started revolting
and getting violent because their
situations were poor yes do you think
that's something that may be happening
in the future as if like uh like during
j6 people were clearly angry but their
anger was directed towards something
else like do you think we are due for
violence
I'm not sure I understand what you're
saying you're saying is it possible that
in the future violence will happen like
on j6 but directed at something
different I I apologize if I'm not
understanding I'm like to the government
like the left side the right side
because people's situations are so
um
it's so like diminished from like back
my parents were were like starting up
and that kind of stuff what's what's
diminished
like the um wages the cost of living uh
opportunity for like housing
like
okay so yeah I I am just not
understanding what you mean so get be so
you're saying housing cost is up wages
are flat so people are upset will that
lead to violence you're saying
um in a sense yes like if um
I'm sorry I was I was still formulating
this question
um
when uh when people like uh I'm sorry
you can skip over me I'm sorry all right
I I appreciate the call it sounds like
there's an interesting question in there
let's uh call back call back when we
figured out what it is and I would I
would love to answer it